you're muted
yeah of course
hey okay everybody can hear me now
ah wait i want to move this zoom grid
for me
okay hi everyone my name is elon yogev
so this talk is about sub quadratic
snarks
in the random oracle model uh
this is joint work with our session
and i'll just start by trying to compete
with
ron's a nostalgic nostalgic slide
which i added just now
but i i want to join him and say that
i truly miss berkeley and the simon
institute and i wish i was there now
this is called compliant there are no
people
yeah he's live streaming
i want to put it here i can't do this
split view i wanted to do a split view
but i
it doesn't seem to work okay
okay so i want to start with the
technical slides
and the subject is succinct arguments
and not just succinct arguments but in
the random local model
um so we talked about these
in in the semester
okay a year ago and i'm assuming
everybody knows
and remembers everything in all the
talks
uh no so i'll give my informal
definition
um so this is a proof system between
approval and a verifier and we have
some language l okay uh deterministic or
non-deterministic language
and a the prover and verifier
both have shared access to this
random oracle okay so this truly random
function
so they have query access to this
function and we're going to denote it
there's zeta in this talk
and the puller is trying to convince the
verifier that x is in the language
and the communication complexity is
succinct
so as opposed to one stock where he
wanted the
the communications complexity to go up
to the witness size
uh here we we want our communication to
be like much less than the witness size
okay and for that of course we'll have
to settle with a
computation of soundness so this is
what's called an argument and not
another proof so let me be
slightly more precise with that um
so what is the security of a snark uh so
we're going to have this t
epsilon security okay we have two
parameters
uh t is going to be the number of
queries and epsilon's
success probability and we're going to
say that aslan has t epsilon security
if any t query unbounded okay so
completion the unbounded adversary p
okay is unbounded but he makes at most
equivalents to the
then the probability over the random
worker okay that he succeeds in
in making the verifier accept okay for
some x that is not in the language of
course
um so this is at most episode
okay so you make t queries and you
can cheat with probability at most
epsilon
and as one said please ask questions and
feel free to unmute yourself
so uh why do we study the random oracle
model well it's a
elegant information theoretic model
it also supports well-known
constructions that we'll talk about
of course you can take these
constructions from this wheeled random
oracle model into reality
by some heuristic implementation of the
random oracle
and constructions in this model are also
plausibly
post quantum secure and actually the
constructions we have
have proven to be post-quantum secure
okay so what constructions do we have
we have two basic constructions so where
mikali 94 and recently bcs this is
bensassonkies and
spooner and they both work under the
same paradigm
so they take a information theoretic
proof
so can you guys see my mouse like is
this also shield
yeah okay so they take a information
theoretical so this would be a pcp in
the case of mikali or an iop in the case
of bcs and thank you one for explaining
about iops so
i can uh i have a similar picture here
but
i guess everybody is now more familiar
with it
um and so they take this pool system
this is an information theoretical
system they take a cryptographic
commitment
okay and this is a going to be the
mercury and this commitment supports
local openings uh and together they
compile them
and get a non-interactive succinct
argument as knock
um so we're going to focus on
mikali's construction here okay uh just
for
mainly for simplicity okay so we have
only one round
uh so what is the construction in
slightly more detail
the approval is going to take the
witness computer pcp of this witness
computer merkel tree okay using the the
random oracle
okay so he's going to use the random
oracle to compress every two nodes to
one node
and so on and so on until he gets load
then he's gonna use the random walker on
this route
okay to derive pcp randomness uh
so here the random worker is gonna take
the route as input
and output as many random bits as the
verifier
of the pcp needs okay
and then the proof is going to contain
this route
all the pcp answers okay to these
queries
and then all the authentication paths
okay so if i want to for example
uh convince you that that this node
was consistent with the root okay this
root is essentially a commitment to this
it's a very short commitment to this
very long string then you need to send
all the the locations on this path and
the enables
so you need to send this the first node
and the second node then we can compute
this one
and then you send this one and we
compute this one and you send this one
we compute this one and so on
okay until the root so this is what the
approval does he writes the pcp computes
the mercury
derives pcp randomness okay from the
root
and then sends the root and all the
authentication paths for all the queries
inside the pcb
what does the verifier do on his end he
verifies the pcp answers and then he
verifies the authentication passes
okay so where this was mikhail's
construction
and this is like a overview of of what
we had
questions up to here let's see if
there's more things
okay uh so
the main question is what is the size of
this
a final argument pi okay and this is
going to be the main topic of this
of this talk is the the size of the
the size of the snog okay the size of
the argument
um oops okay
so just really to sum up my whole talk
uh in one slide uh uh quickly
mikhail's construction has quadratic
argument size
and i'm going to explain exactly what
this is
and we give a sub quadratic argument
size
okay so we'll give a new construction
it's based on wekali but it's a
different construction
and it gets a smaller argument size and
this is really the first improvement to
mikali's construction in many years
okay in terms of the argument size
so i want to explain these in the in
a bit more detail so why what is what do
i mean quadratic size and why michali
has quadratic size and then we'll see
our construction
so let's again think back on mikali's
argument
and suppose you use it with a pcp that
has some length l
over some alphabet sigma and has a query
complexity q
okay so what is the size so first you
know
you write down down cells to the pcp
okay so this is
q times log sigma this is just the the
symbols you need to answer
okay then for every symbol you need to
authenticate it
so you need to send the authentication
path and so you have q
paths okay every path is of length log l
okay more or less so this is the the
length of the path
and then the length of the pass it
contains logan nodes
but every node has output size lambda
well lambda is the output
of the random oracle okay
so we have q times lambda times log l
this is the
the size that we need
um okay but how the how does this
connect back
to the security that we want okay so you
asked me for a snog with security t
epsilon
okay you told me alone please give me a
snug that if you make it mostly queries
your probability of cheating is at most
epsilon
okay then i claim that the the
oracle output must be okay we must set
a lambda to be log t over epsilon
and the pcp query complexity must also
be log t over epsilon
okay and i'm going to explain these two
points uh
but just believe me for a second if you
believe me then the argument size is
quadratic
okay so we have this log t over epsilon
and this is also a log t by epsilon
and for now and in this talk i'm like
going to ignore the
law of the terms okay so they're hiding
in this o tilde
and we have log t of epsilon squared
okay so this is the size of the of the
argument in mikali
okay um
so why why do we need to set these two
parameters like this
so first claim to get the epsilon
security the output
size must be lambda equals log t over
epsilon
so just think of the following attack
okay
think of a cheating pool that is
guessing the route in advance
okay so he really is just guessing the
route in advance
this has probability two to the minus
lambda to succeed
but if it succeeds okay once he knows
the rules
in advance he can derive all the pcp
randomness
uh and then just come up with a pcp that
convinces the verifier
for these particular queries okay so of
course in a pcp like
you need first to commit or pcp and then
get the queries okay if you get the
query styles you can just fold the
verify
so he could just come up with a pcp that
pulls the verifiers
compute the merkle tree and then with
probability two to the minus lambda
it is the wood that he guessed in
advance
okay moreover he can try this t times
okay so you have roughly two times okay
so each time it costs him some queries
but let's just call this one
so he can repeat this process roughly
two times which means that his success
probability is t
times two to the minus lambda you want
this to be at most epsilon
okay because this is a complete attack
then we require that this is
uh this would be atmos epsilon and this
gives us lambda equals log two verbs
okay so what about the number of queries
okay that was lambda what about q
so i claim that the number of queries of
the pcp
or iop okay must be log t over epsilon
also
so why is that so observe that we want
the soundness
to be epsilon over t okay we want the
soundness of the pcp to be epsilon
obviously in particular much smaller
than the soundness
like the soundness l should be much
smaller than the sounds you want for the
snug
and why is that because the cheating
prover
can try in its mind to to compete with
the pcp
so you can just think of trying a random
pcp
okay this random pcp might have a uh
some chance of accepting and then you
can tie this t
times okay so because you can type this
t time we must set uh
the sound is to be epsilon notable t how
do we get
uh a pcp with soundness epsilon over t
um so there are different ways
depending on what pcp you start with
basically what we do we take some pcp
and we amplify it
okay we we do repetitions
uh and just let's think of a standard
pcp so think if
i have a constant sound spcp with
constant queries
okay then the number of repetitions i
need to get this
is log t over epsilon which would mean
that this is the number of
uh um of queries that i have
you have some better pcps and even if
you use like
dream pcps which are really the limit
that we imagine
exist okay and in a previous world with
ali we showed that
you cannot have better pcps or iops
assuming eth then again the only gain
that you have are like a small
it's like a login factor but i'm
ignoring these factors
here okay
so going back a q had to be logged here
over epsilon lambda had to be looked
over epsilon the both sides is log t
over epsilon squared
and you can show one controller low
bound
of log t over epsilon so this we do not
expect to get better than this
and the question is uh what what lies
here in
between okay can we have better
constructions or should we improve the
low bounds
okay so as a result as i said already uh
so it's going to be a sub quadratics now
and more particularly
the theorem says that there exists nulls
in the random vocal model
okay that achieve argument size log t
over epsilon
times log t okay so instead of log t
over epsilon times log t over epsilon
this
you only have this log t factor which
means that
if t is rather small compared to one
over epsilon
then this is really a big improvement
and i wanna highlight the the high level
approach of what we do
so we're gonna start with a strong
information theoretic proof okay so here
i mean that
we're not just going to start with a pcp
with better soundness we already
talked about the limits of that but
actually start with a pcp with a
stronger soundish notion
okay so this is going to be a different
notion than than standard soundness
we're going to use this with a weak
cryptographic commitment so this is
actually not going to be strictly
speaking a commitment scheme
but some weak relaxed version of it
okay that is much cheaper to implement
uh and together we're going to get this
sub
quadratic slope
uh okay so that was the theoretical part
of the
of the statement and uh i want to
emphasize that this is
not only a theoretical result but this
construction can be used in practice
as well so i want to give you some
some numbers so what we did here we
compared it with uh mikali's
construction
on particular sets of the of the in
particular values of tier webserum
uh what we did we take we took some base
pcp
okay so we imagined with that we had a
pcp
with sound and error have quite a
complexity
three and a half length of two to the
thirty
okay um and this was the base pcp that
we used to
to amplify um in reality
you might not have these parameters for
pcps
you might get close to them with an iop
this is just like demonstrating the
numbers if you
plug in something different it changes
both in nikali's construction and in our
construction
okay so this is like some baseline to to
to check the both of them and what you
can see in red
okay in red is uh mikali size in blue is
a is a snug
that we get and uh and so you can see
the differences
and you can see that the best the best
uh improvement we get is here
okay well t is small but one of the
epsilon is large
okay and here we actually get a factor
of two bit
okay so what is the construction
so the starting point as i said of the
construction is we call this
construction so you should still have
this in mind
and a what we're going to do is we're
actually going to set
the oracle output size to be log t
okay roughly and this already
is very good because it solves the
argument size problem
okay so now the argument size is just
going to be q times lambda
which is exactly what what we want
because we set lambda to be smaller
the problem is that if you do this the
construction is just not secure
okay so we lose security
uh so for that we're gonna make four
changes
okay we're gonna make four changes the
mechanic construction
uh we're gonna chop the three we're
gonna use the main separation
we're gonna permit the proof and we're
not just
to use any pcp but we need robust
soundness
okay so these are the fall changes that
we're going to make and
i'm going to describe them but let me
just say that these changes
each and one of them does not increase
the argument size
okay so these are changes that maintain
the same argument size
each one alone does not increase
security but actually all of them
together
combined they do increase security and
because they increase security they
let us reduce the output size of the
random oracle okay to this value that we
set here
and that's how we get the improvement
and also
one last comment is that our analysis
works even where
when you can you assume that you have
salts in the construction
so here i mean that we let the adversary
when he makes some query x
and to the random oracle and he gets
back a response y
so we assume he has like some prefix
some salt that he can control
so you can change this salt and then get
a new response a new why
and our analysis is like even stronger
it's even for adversaries that can do
this
and this is useful for zero knowledge
but in this talk i'm not going to talk
about zero knowledge
okay so the first and maybe the main
change that we do is we chop the tree
so this is michali's construction
okay where we compute the whole tree up
to the root and what we're going to do
we're going to define some layer okay i
start we call this the stop layer
and we're going to uh chop the tree here
okay so the honest mover is going to
write the same pcp compute the mercury
and then at some point it's just going
to stop
this entire layer we call it the cap
okay
and to derive the pcp randomness instead
of running the random oracle on the root
we're gonna run the random orchid and
the entire cap
okay so we're gonna take all the nodes
in this layer
concatenate them treat them as one long
string and run the random organ on this
okay so this is the the chopped tree
um so just some intuition why we use
this
so first um if you set i start to be
zero
this is mikali okay so this is exactly
me
if you set i style to be log l okay
meaning that you chop everything like at
the leaf layer
then this means that you just send the
entire pcp
okay so when you send the entire pcb
like the poover has no no way of
cheating
in terms of the commitment scheme so in
general when i start is larger
we get better and better security okay
but the argument size is larger okay in
particular when i start
equals logan this is just trivial
sending the entire witness
okay and also maybe i want to mention
that this is not like a very good
trade-off
okay the the price you pay for the
argument size
is in general much higher than what you
gain in security
however there is one quotient point
okay one crucial layer and this is where
you set i start to below q
this is a very special layer why because
we have q so q is the number of queries
to the pcp
so anyway even in mikali's construction
we're going to send
q a paths for queue locations
so if you look at layer locu this layer
has q
nodes overall okay with high probability
you're gonna send all of these nodes or
at least most of them
okay a vast majority of them this is
because you're sending you
a few random positions in this move
so if you stop at at layer locu
you get better security and this is
something that we can
actually exploit and you pay nothing in
the in the argument size
okay so this is a an important point
and what is the intuition for better
security
okay why does a higher eye style
gave us better security so in particular
think of the attack that i described
before
where the adversary guesses the route in
advance
okay and if he guesses the route in
advance he knows all the pcp queries
and then you can just come up with a pcp
that he wants
here guessing the entire cap in advance
okay which means guess is guessing all
the nodes in this cap
this is like really impossible okay
there are many nodes here and there's no
you have really small probability of
guessing all of them
what the adversary can do is guess maybe
one of them
or a few of them okay but if you guesses
only one of them
then now this node controls only a small
part of the proof
okay it doesn't control the entire pcp
in particular if we have q nodes here
then it this
this one node controls only a one over q
fraction of the proof
okay so um
change number two this is domain
separation
so what we're going to do we're going to
use a different oracle
for every single location in the tree
okay and what does that mean okay
either i have many orchids or i just
have one but that you can just add that
prefix
okay for all queries with i and j
where your query is for the eye level
and jth
position inside the tree and
intuitively this prevents reusing
inversion or collisions
okay so if i found because in our
construction actually
finding a collision or inversion is
gonna happen okay like a cheating prover
would have a probability of doing this
and we want to make sure he cannot reuse
one collision in many positions
okay so we're going to add this prefix
so for example this node would be like 1
1 this node would be 1 2 this node would
be 2 1 and so on
and you would just add these prefixes
for every query that you make
to make sure that like a collision here
is different than a collision here
okay change number three permuting the
proof
so we're gonna permute the pcp proof
before applying
the chopped merkle tree uh so
this means that we're gonna promote the
locations of the proof
okay how they ordered over the
in the leaves so for simplicity i'm just
going to assume i have access
to a random permutation over the
locations one to l
okay um if you're worried about
you know this assumption that i assume
the random permutation
so first you can derive this permutation
from a random molecule this is called
the
in general the lubi rock of permutation
and actually you don't really need a
permutation and the random function will
will suffice here but again i just think
of having a permutation
and the what is the effect of this the
effect of this
is as imagining that we have a pcp with
uniform random
uniform independent random queries okay
so if you had queries at the position
one
two and three after the permutations
you're just going to go to uniform
random positions
and even for simplicity you can just
imagine that we started with a
completely uniform pcp and then you
don't need this fermentation actually
um okay so now the changes instead of
writing the pcp
in the order that the pcp tells you
you're going to compute the
pcp and then compute the permutation of
this pcp and then write it here
so this is change number three and the
last one is that
we're not going to use any pcp but we
need some
robust sound as pcp uh
so we introduced uh some new notion of
the
of a pcp soundness we called permuted
robust pcps
ron talked slightly about these robust
pcps
so this is similar only with a
permutation before
and the intuition that i want to convey
here is that
even if a approval changes
a few number of locations after the fact
so after seeing the the queries of the
very fire
know how harm is made okay uh
so i'll give a slightly more uh
technical definition
but what we're gonna have is a parameter
b
b is gonna be the number of blocks okay
because i don't wanna
consider each and every symbol of the
proof but we're going to
consider them in blocks and we're going
to assume we have some
permutation okay
and i'm going to define a distance
measure
so the distance between two pull spine
pi prime
is going to be the block wise this
distance between the two strings
okay so really if these are my two
strings
okay then you can see that they are all
exactly the same
okay in all the blocks except this block
okay this block has two symbols that are
different
but they're both in the same block so
the distance is one
okay just a blockwise distance between
these two blocks
and again the blocks are not like
positions one two three
but these are the positions one two
three after i permuted the proof
okay so the blocks are actually going to
be like a random
random blocks it's like uh randomly
permuting the the proof taking the
blocks
and then looking at the distance
okay so using this i can define what our
permuted robust pcp is
um so we're going to say that the pcp
has permitted robust sound is epsilon
okay and we have two parameters the
blocks this is a
more rather fixed parameter that we're
just going to have in mind
and the other parameter is the distance
d okay so we're going to have some
distance
parameter and we're going to say that it
has a
robustness epsilon if the probability of
this game
okay instead of the standards on this
game is at most epsilon
um so what is the game so first the game
publishes a random permutation pi
okay that everybody can see the cheating
pool is going to output some
pcp string pi okay
then we're going to sample a pcp
randomness raw
okay so this is the the randomness for
the verifier
and as opposed to standard pcp well now
we will check
for this randomness like does he accept
the proof here we're going to give back
this underneath to the cheat improver
okay so we're giving back this
randomness
the cheating approval needs to output
another pcp string
a pi prime and this can be as a function
of
all okay but when we are going to accept
the game outputs one okay accepts
if and only if um the distance between
pi and pi prime is at most d
okay and again in this distance measure
that we had
uh so you can change at most d blocks of
the proof pi that he originally
committed to
and of course the verifier accepts a
pipeline
okay so this is going to be the
definition of robust
permuted robust soundness
um okay so
one additional technical definition is
that um we're gonna say that a pcp has
robustness
ratio better okay if for any d
you look at how harm how much harm does
it make
to let the proverb change one more block
okay so what is the ratio between the
soundness when he is allowed to change
d plus one blocks uh compared to only
changing d
blocks and if you can uh bound this
ratio by beta then we say that
the pcp has robust insulation beta
okay so this is the final construction
you take merkel
you chop the tree that's one okay at
some level i start
you add domain separation that is two
you permute the proof that is three
and you don't use any proof you also use
robust epcps that's four
and let me also just hint because i'm
not sure how much time i will have
uh if you're worried about how i get
these robust pcps
uh then what we show is actually any
repeated
pcp is a robust pcp
okay so you don't have to worry about
this too much
uh questions about the construction
uh hi alan hi nick yeah
uh could you go back to the the
definition of this robustness
i just understand um
okay so so here the the everybody knows
the permutation it's a
yeah everybody knows the permutation
just some permutation over
the locations um what's this delta
perm yeah so this is
this is the distance between two pools
yeah but the distance is not like the
hamming distance
okay i'm gonna count how many blocks are
different
okay okay and so the picture
is the here okay so in this example i
have two strings
they're exactly the same everywhere
except in this block so the distance is
one
uh i see okay so the the this is a
because the hamming distance is
invariant under permutations but this
block waste distance is not
exactly yes yes so if it was just
hamming distance the permutation would
mean
nothing but because i'm not looking
exactly at hamming distance but just
said blocks
i want to make sure that i don't have
like one important block
and one other block where the verifier
never queries
like anything i want to make sure that
every block like would have uh
the same amount of queries more or less
with high probability
so that's why like i'm permitting
everything all right thanks
okay thank you
for breaking the ice on questions in
fact i want to you know as moderator
please
please ask questions uh and also those
of you who feel comfortable uh if you
turn on the video it might help a little
bit more
interactions yeah oh yeah
okay thanks
yeah okay thank you
try to continue okay
so this was the construction let me see
that you know
just just earlier about time uh i think
five six more minutes okay
okay so i'll try to say something about
the proof
uh so the proof is shown in two steps
the first step is saying okay just
assume i have a pcp
which doesn't only have soundness but
also has
permitted robust soundness okay so this
is a strong pcp
and then i'll show that if you start
with such a strong pcp
and you commit to it okay with this
chopped tree with domain separation and
the permutation
then you get the snog that we want uh
and then the second step would be to
construct such pcps and as i already
said
to construct these pcps it's not like
that we build them from ground
we show that if you take any base pcp
and
and repeat it and amplify it actually
what you get is uh
is this basically um
okay so the main lemma for the first
part that we show
is that if you give me any pcp that has
soundness epsilon
and permuted robustness ratio better
okay
so the we can bound the the ratio by
beta
and lambda is more or less log t okay
it has to be two log t plus log beta
plus three
okay so we really worked hard on the
constants here
um and you take the the
uh the stop layer to be such that two to
the i star is b
okay so this would exactly correspond
between
uh the blocks uh for the roots
of this top layer okay the number of
blocks in the in the robust pcp
then you have soundness t times epsilon
pcp
okay which is what we want
and a for this proof we introduce
something that we call scores of oracle
queries this is
a very simple but helpful tool that i'll
show you
uh and then we use them to reduce any
cheating pool
to a strategy of the permuted robust
soundness
so let me just quickly say what i mean
by scoring
oracle queries um
[Music]
so in our construction an adversary
might be able to find collisions okay
and this is because we set the
the security parameter to be quite small
okay
in particular it could be the case that
the probability that he finds a
collision
is half okay
what i want to do is is somehow score
a give us call to his queries okay
for example if he found one collision i
want to give him like some score
if he found a hundred collisions then i
want to give him a very high score
okay then i'm going to say that the
probability of
a trace that has a very high score is
going to be very small
okay but this is going to be something
small
so uh the score of a ky collision
so i'm looking at the trace of queries
that some adversary did to the random
overkill
if this trace contains a k-wise
collision
i'm going to give it a count of k minus
1. okay in particular every standard
collision is going to get one point
okay so i look at the trace i just count
how many collisions or how many
how many k collisions i sum all of them
and this is the
this is going to be the score collision
okay
uh we're also going to score inversions
uh so what is an inversion we're going
to count the number of queries
where the response of the query was some
value y
okay and this value y hit some previous
query
x1 x2 okay so this corresponds to like
inverting the
the random oracle okay we did not expect
uh the cheating pouvel to perform some
query
well the output is some string that he
already clearly
quoted in the past okay
uh so we're gonna count the number of
occurrences that we have
okay of uh of an inversion and
um there are different ways to define
these these calls
uh but i think what we use like
is meaningful and well at least useful
and what we show is that if you have any
algorithm
that makes at most t queries okay
then the probability that the collision
score is more than k
is going to be more or less t squared
over 2 to the lambda
okay so this is expected from the
birthday paradox
to the power of k okay so even if this
is just like half
okay so probability of a collision is
half probability of getting square k
is like a decaying exponentially with k
and the same thing more or less holds
for inversions
okay so you can ignore the small factors
but just it also
goes down there with k
okay and then to prove
to prove the soundness of our
construction okay it's going to look as
follows
so what is the probability that the
verifier accepts
so we're gonna sum over all k from zero
to infinity
and we're gonna say okay let's condition
on the verifier
um what's the probability that the
verifier accepts
condition on the cheating prover
achieving a score of k
times the probability of achieving a
score of k
okay and k just runs into into infinity
now what we show that
um so once you fixed you conditioned on
the cheating pool and having a score of
k
so we can find that most k collisions or
at most k inversions or any mix of those
and
we show that we can reduce this to the
uh
to the soundness game of the pcp okay
the permitted robust soundness game
this is like a major technical step
that you should be glad that i'm sparing
you okay
uh and surely i don't have time i want
to finish like in one minute
uh but just intuitively why do we get
this
this this thing so first he can try
as i said he can try to invert like if
you give him a score of k
he can invert k nodes okay so he can't
play the
the permitted robustness on his game
with the distance of k
okay so he can commit to some pcp see
the queries and then invert k
nodes so we can create something of
distance k
he can also find k collisions so it's
not really committed
to one proof so he gains this additional
factor of two to the k
because when he finds collisions then he
can mix and match between them
and he can actually commit to one of two
to decay
er proofs and then also we have this
factor of t
this is because it can do everything
again and again t times
okay or at least at most t times
um then using the
robustness ratio plus the score lemma
okay so this purple score here
this we just replace with the
probability of getting skull k
and this permutation permitted on by
soundness
we replace it with better to the k times
epsilon pcp
okay because this is the ratio so for k
equals zero it's just
it just you have no distance it's just
epsilon
for k equals 1 you have a one way
multiplication of beta and so on
and then you just take t and epsilon
outside and you have this
infinite sum but this infinite sum
converges because how we chose lambda
okay so it's gonna converge to some
constant and actually in the proof we
get like the constant here to be one
okay not uh
so i guess i'm out of time right
i confirm yeah so i would just say that
the second step is going to be
constructing a
permitted robust pcps
and we have this lemon that i don't have
time to explain but shows that you can
take any base pcp repeat it and actually
get
some robustness ratio uh and
when you plug everything in uh you
you can prove our argument size and i'll
just conclude by saying that
what we have shown we have shown snugs
that have size log t over epsilon times
log t
um there is a lower bound of log t over
epsilon
and the big major open question here is
like does there exist nogs in the random
oval
that achieve size log t over epsilon
if this question is answered positively
positively this would be like a a huge
huge benefit uh on the stunts we have
uh okay thank you great thank you along
club club um other
questions for them
quick question just if you an
intermediate question would be to
replace log t by log one over epsilon do
you have any insights on that
yeah that's a great question that would
be like uh
the dual version of our construction
right
actually we we don't have such a
construction
any intuition i
the intuition is like asking me if this
open problem is
uh can we solve it positively or
negatively and i'm not sure
i'm not uh
yeah and i want to say that for
practical purposes
like maybe this exact open problem is
not
the most important one but still using
these techniques you might
er like improve other smaller older
terms that they didn't talk about
which have like significant practical
implications
okay thanks but i'm not sure about this
open problem like i have no idea
i also have a question um so your
analysis reminds me of
uh work by i think batons clients about
showing that
some variant of killian is secure if you
only use multi-collision resistant hash
functions
it seems like you're saying that with if
you set the root of this merkle tree to
be small enough then you
might be able to find collisions but you
can't really find very large
multi-collisions
so is there a have you is there a
relation between your analysis and that
or can you use
uh bkp in a kind of black box way
you got a similar result uh yeah that's
a good question
we do not use their uh a result
um so um yeah they have something in a
similar flavor
right they use a multicollision distinct
hash
and then they don't get quite uh a
commitment scheme
they get something relaxed and then they
also show a pcp
with a stronger soundness notion where
even in if you commit you don't really
commit to the
to the pcp this is a pcp like over a
large alphabet
and for every location you commit to
like a list of symbols
so the cheating borders committed to
this list and then
and they also show like a transformation
that
that goes from a standard pcp to this
stronger pcp
um so we don't use the result and i
don't think that we
even can so for sure for practical
matters like the result would not be
good
uh but even for theoretical ones
like what the cheating proverb can do in
our scheme
is very very different in their scheme
eventually what he can do is commit to a
list of symbols at every location
and in our scheme it's very different he
can find
collisions and he can actually
like there might be a locations where he
can
open to two to the k uh possibilities
uh after the seeing the the
the randomness of the very fire he can
do some other changes
uh so it's it's a different game but
it's similar in the co
in like the smell
similar flavor
are any further questions
and okay so if not we have a
uh lunch slash breakfast lunch
in the break right now
to i'm gonna sort of resume in uh just a
little over an hour
uh for uh for those of you that feel
like it we do have like uh sort of this
uh
gather.town link i'm gonna put it here
for socializing
i definitely at least like to encourage
the speakers for the past two talks to
hang out there for a bit and see if
there are any additional talks
uh i'll myself be hanging out there
while i fix up some food for myself
uh yes i link to the
the the the i put it in chat no sorry i
didn't put the job i put it in a loan
strap
uh and i put it in chat for everybody
yeah
um and so we'll uh we'll resume uh
over here at noon california
with we have two more talks i think uh
at the intersection of
blockchains and and uh law
and and econ so please stick around
thank you to those speakers for the
morning sessions and with excellent
talks
all right see you over there